attention pour le moment c'est de
refroidir les réacteurs qui sont encore
alimenter si je comprends bien par
l'électricité donc il n'y a pas un
danger immédiat mais il faudrait
refroidir les réacteurs pour encore plus
réduire le danger est temps que la
centrale est encore occupée par les
forces russes je pense que l'ukraine un
peu c'est un peu résigné à ne pas
recevoir et électricité de cette
centrale peut être que les occupants
russes vont vouloir essayer de le
rallumer il reconnecter avec avec la
crimée mais pour le moment ils dépendent
d'ingénieurs ukrainien sur le site alors
c'est difficile à savoir ce qui va
arriver à l'avenir en tout cas l'ukraine
même si c'est un coût pour l'économie du
pays bien sûr de perdre une centrale
aussi importante elle fournissait avec
jusqu'à ya pas longtemps 20% de
l'électricité du pays mais l'ukraine a
tout de même un surplus d'électricité
elle est même en train de négocier c'est
le président hélène ski qui l'a annoncé
ce week-end avec la pologne pour
augmenter les livraisons d'électricité à
la pologne l'ukraine annonce que les
troupes ont repris sur le terrain plus
de 3000 kilomètres carrés de territoire
jusqu'où peut aller la contre-offensive
ukrainienne
alors justement maintenant les attentes
en ukraine sont très très importante il
y a quelques jours les ukrainiens ne s'y
attendait pas du tout à ce que leur
armée arrive à avancer aussi rapidement
pour mettre les choses en perspective
c'est seulement en quatre jours que les
forces armées de l'ukraine ont réussi à
reprendre pris plus de trois mille
kilomètres carrés c'est plus que ce que
les russes avaient réussi à conquérir en
quatre mois depuis le mois d'avril mais
maintenant même si les ukrainiennes s'y
attendait pas ma non ils veulent qu lui
s'il y a eu des sortes de promesses qui
ont été faits notamment par le
gouverneur de la région de loin que qui
a dit que dans les prochains jours on
pourrait voir des villes et des
localités importantes dans la région de
loin de libérer deux sous l'occupation
russe est pour le moment aujourd'hui il
y a eu à moins d'un ans - de nouvelles
photos sur internet qui apparaissent
pour annoncer de nouvelles avancées
alors tout le monde se demande un peu si
l'offensive va devoir ralentir ou si on
va bientôt avoir encore plus de bonnes
nouvelles si vous voulez